In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for October 1st, on which we commemorate, the holy protection
of the most holy Thelthokos, the solemnity of the holy protection of our sovereign lady,
the Mother of God, and ever virgin Mary.
The feast of the holy protection of the Mother of God was established following a vision of
our Holy Father Andrew, the fool for Christ, during the course of a vigil in the Church
of Blacierne at Constantinople.
At the fourth hour of the night, while deep in prayer, the saint lifted up his eyes to heaven,
and to be held the holy Mother of God, watching over the congregation as she covered the faithful
with her veil.
Epiphanios, the disciple of Saint Andrew, who was also accounted worthy of looking upon
this wonder, confirmed the truth of the vision, whereupon the saint hastened to the altar,
opened the coffer containing the precious veil of the queen of the world, and standing in front
of the royal doors, extended it above the worshipers.
Upheld by an invisible power, the veil hung in the air, and was of such size, as entirely
to cover the great congregation.
Then amid a shattering burst of light, the Mother of God went up into heaven and out of sight,
but leaving the Christian people in possession of her holy veil as a pledge of her loving protection.
Many a time did the Mother of God give clear evidence of her protection of the imperial
city, and by analogy of the entire holy church of Christ, which is the New Jerusalem.
Indeed, everywhere and at every moment, the sovereign lady of the world casts her veil
mystically over Christians as she makes prayer and intercession for the salvation of the world
to her son and our Lord.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.